Và phá đoạn uc quan nào và ngang 1,5 đá khép là ngày làm việc đầu tiên của họ còn họ đảm bà bên dòng ý bảo chờ tại Abu Dabi với đánh giá từ kỳ quãi nào là hiệu quả và thực chất.
Ông đứa sáng umero, thực kỳ hội đồng an ninh và khu phòng uc quan nào đông thời là trường đoạn đà phán uc quan nào cho biết
các cuộc thảo luận tập trung vào những bước đi cuộc thề và giải pháp thực tiến.
Một quan trưng Mỹ zong tiền cũng sang giận tiền trình thích cực và cho biết, đà phán sẽ tiếp tục trong ngày thứ 2.
Phá biểu của ngày tổng thống uc quan nào bố lối đi mê ra xe kỳ nhận mạnh, tiến trình đà phán cần giận tởi hoa bình thực sự.
Đông thời kỳ vọng sớm đát đường một thỏa thuận chào đổi tụi bình mới.
Mà dù vậy, thác con gồn tìm ngoại giao, những bất đồng có loại vận có lớn,
đặc biệt là yêu cầu của ngà về lạnh thổ ở miền đà uc quan nào và tương loại của nhà bấy định hạnh nhân gia phùi ria.
Uc quan nào bác bỏ những bộ lạnh thổ và để sất đồng bóng sông đồ kéo tiến kiểm soát hiện nay.
Đây là vòng đám phá thứ 2 của cơ trẻ bà bên ngà, mi uc quan nào,
nó tiếp của các độ tiền dễn gia tạch tu air của hi tháng trước.
Trong một dễ biệt liên quan tạch chiến sức,
cùng ngày mùi tổ tháng 2 trong uc quan phòng bệnh bởi kênh chuyênện phòng xa 2.
Tổng thống uc quan nào bố lối đi mê ra xe kỳ cho biết,
khoảng 5.000 biến sĩ uc quan nào đã thiệt mạch chiến trường kể tự kỳ xong độc với ngà đủ phát.
Mọi gia có một số lượng lượng bình xí mất tích.